Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Fuck. Moin.
Moin Leute.
Boah, ja, exzellent, exzellent.
Ich bin zwar schon irgendwie 40 Minuten wach, aber ich bin nicht wirklich wach, ist ja so, also halb wach.
So. Irgendwie kommen auf meinem Vorschaubildschirm wieder irgendwelche Chatnachrichten nicht an, das ist auch ziemlich bebäger.
So, müssen wir mal refreshen, vielleicht geht es dann.
Mal kurz testen. Keg. KegU. Ja, jetzt kommt es gleichzeitig an.
Okay, müssen wir einfach mal den Browser-Tab refreshen. Hat sich Chrome gedacht. Nee, machen wir nicht, kein Bock.
Chrome. Warum heißt Chrome eigentlich Chrome?
Weil Google Chrome ist Chrome.
Okay, jetzt kriegen wir es erklärt. Der Zoomer muss kurz weg.
Also, product must name Chrome. Codename.
Die dümmste, naheliegendste Antwort ist in dem Fall tatsächlich richtig.
Autos und Geschwindigkeit. Das ist ja langweilig. Dachte, das hätte vielleicht irgendwelche spannenderen Hintergründe, warum Chrome Chrome heißt.
Naja, nee, bin ich nicht.
Leute, ich habe Cobalt letztes Jahr. Brauchen wir fort dran dieses Jahr.
Ja, Leute. Seid ihr schon wach? Also ich nicht. Ich befinde mich so in einem halb wachen Zustand.
Ich kann mich gar nicht dazu überreden, jetzt meine Maus in die Hand zu nehmen und irgendwas zu klicken.
Habt ihr schöne, ich habe Socken gekriegt. Die übliche Geschichte.
Ich habe Socken gekriegt. Bist noch wach, Pog.
Buch, richtig old school. Betrucktes Papier.
Du hast einen Xbox 360 Elite Controller bekommen. Das ist tatsächlich nice. Die gibt es ja so neu nicht mehr.
Ach Moment, du hast so einen normalen Controller gekriegt.
Weil die gibt es gar nicht mehr zu kaufen. Wenn du hier nach Xbox gerade wired, nicht weird champ wired, ist also
wirklich wirklich schwierig zu finden. Also die gibt es kaum noch zu kaufen.
Das ist alles, das ist alles fake. Guck, seht ihr hier, das ist, das ist alles fake.
Das ist der originale. Das andere ist alles fake.
360 Old Controller gibt es nicht mehr. Alles nur fake. Ich habe zum Glück noch einen.
Aber ist alles, alles fake.
Das ist glaube ich so, das dürfte ja so mit der billigste Schraubmaterialerzeiten sein hier.
Alles fake, das sieht man nachher, dass es halt kein Xbox Logo drauf hat. Das ist ein Yes Team und, und
Yai Yei. Oder Diswo. Alles fake.
Und wenn schon, kommt mir nur der Original. Ich muss euch ja ehrlich sagen, ich finde der Xbox 360 Controller ist der beste Controller.
Der Xbox One Controller bzw. der Xbox Series S Controller. Ich weiß nicht, was da der Unterschied ist, ob ich mal was geändert habe.
Da sind mir die Analog-Sticks zu klein oben.
Also, weiß nicht, irgendwie war der Xbox 360 Controller so für mich peak, peak Controller.
PS5 Controller könnte tatsächlich noch nice sein. Die Sache ist die, warum ich den PlayStation Controller noch nie mochte ist,
der hat auch kleinere Analog-Sticks und der ist so, vielleicht ist es jetzt besser geworden,
aber der ist so klein im Vergleich zu dem Xbox 360 Controller.
Beim Xbox 360 Controller fand ich gut. Du hattest halt wirklich das Ding fest in der Hand und musstest nicht selbst so fest halten,
weil das Ding so klein ist.
Der ist groß. Vielleicht sollte ich mal, ich bräuchte ja noch mal ein paar Controller für den PC. Ich habe ja nur mal einen Xbox 360 Controller noch.
Vielleicht sollte ich mal einen anderen ausprobieren. Ahja. Egal.
Aber was machen die Japaner? Gibt es dann in Japan einen kleineren?
Weil ich habe früher immer als Argument gehört, ja ist doch ganz klar, die PlayStation kommt ja aus Japan,
die Japaner haben kleinere Hände und deswegen kleine Controller.
Das war also das Standard-Argument, warum der PlayStation Controller so klein ist.
Und wie ist das jetzt bei der PS5? Ist der in Japan kleiner?
Oder kommen jetzt auf magische Art und Weise die Leute da doch mit klar?
Weil das war ja so das Argument schlechthin, was die Leute früher immer gebracht haben.
Adaptive Trigger ist wirklich eine nice Geschichte.
Es gibt ja sogar auch Tastaturen, die sowas haben.
Da kannst du dann theoretisch die Tasten unterschiedlich tief runterdrücken und anders drauf reagieren.
Excellent. So, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an? 100% Allmann.
Der geilste Kleingärtner. Nee, das müssen wir uns jetzt nicht angucken.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was Autoklember sein soll. Was ist Autoklember?
Meint der Kleimber? Nee, Klember. Was ist ein Autoklember?
Kein Schimmer.
Das Super-Video ist jetzt in deiner Empfehlung, ja. Ich hab sogar noch eins aufgemacht von dem gucken.
Also das Gamestar-Video zur derzeit in der Spielbranche gesehen,
also wenn du das von Maurice meinst, wo im Titel sowas steht wie
ihr seid den Herstellern egal, dann haben wir uns das angeguckt, ja.
Oder wir haben besser gesagt darauf reacted, wie man das heute so schön nennt.
Aktuelle Corona-Zahlen. Mittlerweile muss ich sagen, interessiert mich das alles sowas von gar nicht mehr.
Ich glaub das ging jedem so, ne. Ich hab das ja am Anfang täglich verfolgt, wie sich das so entwickelt,
aber seit über einem Jahr oder so geht das einfach so ins eine Ohr rein, ins andere Ohr raus.
Juckt mich so gar nicht mehr. Spätestens seit ich mich hab impfen lassen, gehts mir noch mehr am Arsch vorbei.
Was übrigens der hauptsächliche Grund ist, warum ich mich hab impfen lassen.
Ich hab mich nicht impfen lassen, also ich will jetzt da gar nicht irgendwie großartig Sachen sagen, die nicht stimmen, ne.
Weil ich hab mich nicht impfen lassen für Solidarität und Nächstenliebe.
Ich hab mich impfen lassen, dass ich selbst keine Probleme krieg, fertig.
Rest ist mir scheißegal. Was interessiert mich die Menschheit? Hauptsache ich kratz nicht ab.
Ich hab mich rein aus Eigennutzen impfen lassen.
So und seitdem verfolge ich das auch überhaupt nicht mehr.
Ich hab mir gedacht, warum auch, ne.
Mein gut, jetzt hast du die Geschichte mit, gibt jetzt neue Corona-Variante, aber das wird garantiert nicht die letzte Corona-Variante sein.
Also mich würd's nicht wundern, wenn wir dann, was ist eigentlich Omikron für nen Buchstabe im griechischen Alphabet?
Was entspricht denn das? A, B, C, D, E, F, G oder sowas?
Keine Ahnung. Griechisches Alphabet.
Okay, zeig mal her.
Alpha, Beta, Gamma, Delta, Epsilon, Zeta, Eta, Teta, Iota hab ich noch nie gehört.
Kappa, Kappa HD, Golden Kappa Check.
Lambda, Mi, Ni, Xi, Omega, ah okay.
Also quasi A, B, C, D, E, F, G, H, I, J, K, L, M, N, O.
O, O entspricht das, okay.
Aber der Rest stimmt, also es könnte auch so einfach sein.
Also es heißt, danach kommt die Pi-Variante.
Pi ist vielleicht schon ein bisschen doppeldeutig belegt im Vorfeld.
Oh, hier, Sigma-Variante ist am Start.
Das ist dann die Chat, die Corona-Chat-Variante.
Also quasi die, da ist dann vorbei.
Oh, das wird eh nicht das erste sein.
Was uns da halt, also ist ja nicht das erste.
Da kommen eh noch mehrere Varianten.
Also da muss man sich glaube ich die nächsten Jahre über darauf einstellen.
Was ich halt geil fand, was ich halt nur geil fand ist,
so irgendwie im Sommer, oder warte, sagen wir mal so,
letztes Jahr im TikTok-Cringe.
Ich watche ja auch kein TikTok-Cringe.
Letztes Jahr, so um diese Zeit herum,
hat man erzählt so nach dem Motto, ja,
obwohl man es eigentlich hätte besser wissen müssen,
hat man so erzählt, ja, also wir machen jetzt nochmal ganz kurz Lockdown
und dann sind wir ja kurz vorm Ziel und alles ist wieder gut.
Und dann hat sich das das letzte Jahr über so hingezogen
und dieses Jahr pünktlich zum Winter haben alle gesagt,
was, wo kommt denn jetzt Corona auf einmal wieder her?
Da hätte ja absolut niemand mit rechnen können,
dass das dieses Jahr im Winter wieder akut wird.
Wo kommt das auf einmal, ist es wieder da?
Komplett, ohne dass man hätte das vermuten können im Vorfeld.
Da haben alle so super überrascht getan, so nach dem Motto,
was, da ist es ja wieder.
Nein, im Leben nicht.
Das ist wie die vier Feinde der deutschen Bahn, genau.
Frühling, Sommer, Herbst und Winter.
Ist auch immer wieder, auf einmal konnte niemand mit rechnen,
dass es direkt Winter ist.
Juli Genetics, Dankeschön für den normaler Sub.
Nee, also das fand ich auch lustig.
Auf einmal ist es wieder am Start.
Das ist auch so was, was ich nicht verstehe.
Man hätte sich ja im Vorfeld schon im Sommer,
als es nicht so akut war, Pläne machen können,
was man macht, wenn es im Winter wieder akut wird.
Aber hat man irgendwie ausgesessen und sich gedacht,
nee, nee, wir stecken jetzt den Kopf in den Sand
und machen mal lieber nichts.
Und dann müssen wir uns nämlich, wenn es dann im Winter
wieder akut wird, wahnsinnig schnell wieder
irgendwelche komischen Konferenzen einberufen,
die dann nachts bis um 3.50 Uhr gehen.
Weil es ja bekannt ist, dass man nachts um 3.00 Uhr
die besten Entscheidungen trifft.
Das gibt es auch nicht, die kann ich nicht so ganz nachvollziehen.
Also ich hab im Februar,
hab ich Auffrischung, nee, wie nennt man?
Boosterimpfung, nicht Auffrischung.
Auffrischung ist ja out.
Es ist ja Booster mittlerweile.
Wobei dann die Frage ist, ob das im Februar
überhaupt noch sinnvoll ist, wenn 99% Omikron
ist und das dagegen gar nicht richtig hilft.
Mal gucken.
Wisst ihr, was das Beste ist?
Versus Corona wenig Kontakt zu Menschen haben.
Easy.
Und da hab ich keine Probleme mit.
Nachdem mir andere Menschen eh auf den Sack gehen,
ah ja, und Hände waschen, nachdem mir andere
Menschen eh auf den Sack gehen, einfach nicht rausgehen.
Einfach nicht rausgehen und einfach sich,
kein Kontakt mit anderen Menschen.
Easy, hab ich überhaupt kein Problem mit.
Andere Menschen nerven mich eh.
So wenig wie möglich.
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, wo am Anfang
erzählt wurde, ich meine, da hat es ja laufen,
das ist ja, du musst ja eigentlich nur mal so
ein paar Monate warten, dann ist ja oftmals das,
was heute quasi als, so muss es sein, dargestellt wird,
nicht unbedingt, nicht mal aktuell.
Könnt ihr euch noch am Anfang dran erinnern,
wo es hieß so nach dem Motto, also Masken bringen
ja gar nichts, weil das geht da ja durch,
das ist ja viel zu klein und Leute,
kauft euch keine Masken, das bringt ja gar nichts.
Kauft, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Und irgendwie dann ein halbes Jahr später so nach dem
Motto, ja jetzt müsst ihr aber alle eine Maske aufziehen.
Ich hab mich von Anfang an ehrlich gesagt,
also gefragt, so nach dem Motto, warum soll das denn
nichts bringen? Ich mein, okay,
natürlich ist so ein Virus kleiner als vielleicht
irgendwelche Maschen in der Maske.
Aber das ist ja in der Luft drin oder eventuell
im, weiß ich so im, in der Luft Feuchtigkeit
irgendwie drin und wenn die Hälfte davon an der Maske
hängen bleibt, warum, natürlich bringt das was.
Also ich hab da keinen Plan von, aber es klang
für mich von Anfang an irgendwie unlogisch,
dass es nichts bringen soll. Egal, es hat sich ja
im Nachhinein rausgestellt, man hat das nur behauptet,
damit die Leute nicht wie für Rückwassen kaufen.
Ja, Osterruhe und dann gab's noch einmal den,
jetzt ist wieder alles Erlaubtag und solche
Dinger, meine Güte.
Das ganze Hickhack da drumherum.
Wer also das da dran geforscht wurde, ob Masken
jetzt was bringen oder nicht, das halte ich jetzt
ja mal für ein Gerücht, dass ich das irgendwie
da drin habe.
An irgendwelchen Forschungsergebnissen.
Also ich mein, ob Masken ja was bringen oder nicht,
das wusstest du von Anfang an und es ist ja auch
mittlerweile rausgekommen, dass man das einfach nur
gesagt hat, dass die Leute nicht wie für Rückwassen
kaufen gehen, sodass man genug für medizinische
Einrichtungen hat. Kann man sagen ehrenwertes Ziel,
aber wahrscheinlich nicht unbedingt das, um Vertrauen
da zu schaffen.
Ansonsten ja, gebe ich dir recht, aber trotzdem,
auch wenn sich aktuelle Erkenntnisse oder Ansichten
dazu ändern, man muss das halt ordentlich erklären.
Und gerade wenn man heute A sagt und morgen B und B
steht im Kontrast zu A, muss man das sinnvoll
begründen oder erklären, nachvollziehbar erklären,
dass das so ist.
Und so Sachen wie ab, keine Ahnung, 190 Quadratmeter
ist alles in Ordnung und ab 200 Quadratmeter
ist böse, muss extra, ergibt es ja auch keinen Sinn.
Da hätte man ganz klar sagen müssen, ja wir haben
das halt willkürlich irgendwo festgelegt.
Also, das ist echt nicht so glücklich gelaufen alles
kommunikationstechnisch, das war schon ziemlich
für'n Arsch an vielen Stellen. Genauso wie man
gesagt hat, dass diese, wie erfassend bei Restaurants
war da gewesen ist, dass es rein zur Nachverfolgung
von Infektionsketten dient und jetzt kommt halt raus
und nach dem auch, ne ne, wir doch für alles andere
verwendet. Das mag alles okay sein, aber man kann
es halt nicht am Anfang behaupten und es danach
nicht machen und sich dann wundern, warum glaubt
nicht keiner mehr was. Hä? Das ist ja logisch.
Ich mein, wenn du 500 mal Scheiße erzählst bekommst,
501. Mal hat man es dann vielleicht irgendwann
gecheckt, dass man es nicht mehr glaubt. Was halt
gerade jetzt ein bisschen doof ist, weil das immer
mehr Leute dazu bringt, dass sie vielleicht ins andere
Lager wechseln und so sagen sie nach dem Wort,
jetzt mach ich gar nichts mehr.
Ah ja, ich denke das wird uns auf jeden Fall noch
eine Weile begleiten und ich denke auch nicht,
dass Omikron das letzte sein wird, was wir kriegen
in der Richtung.
Da kommt bestimmt noch mehr.
Wir haben ja gerade nachgeguckt, als nächstes kommt dann
Pi und dann kommt Ro und spätestens bei Sigma geht
die Welt unter, da ist vorbei.
Dann ist Schluss.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich Winter 2023 oder so
ist Sigma Corona am Start.
So.
Experiment V24.
Minecraft. Warum kriege ich Minecraft Sachen empfohlen?
Okay, lass mich raten. Der sprengt jetzt alles in die
Luft und dann macht sie Bum.
Ja.
Okay.
Ah, das ist ein Amboss oder was?
Das könntest du auf normalem Java Edition Server
wahrscheinlich gar nicht machen, weil der komplette
Server zusammenbrechen würde vor Lag.
Okay, die Grube explodiert.
Alles klar, da hätte ich jetzt auch mit gerechnet,
ehrlich gesagt, bei so viel TNT.
Okay, was auch immer.
Man sollte vielleicht nicht Scheiße erzählen, obwohl
man weiß, dass es nicht so ist.
Ich erwarte ja gar nicht, dass das alles 100% stimmt,
immer, was man sagt.
Aber wenn sich halt rausstellt, es war totaler Bullshit,
dann sollte man das wenigstens auch mal erwähnen.
Und nicht so tun, so nach dem Motto, ich habe gestern
Scheiße erzählt und es alles richtig verkauft und heute
verkaufe ich wieder was als richtig und das wird
wahrscheinlich auch wieder richtig sein.
Da muss man halt auch mal sagen können, okay, Datenlage
hat sich geändert, was auch immer.
Und aus diesen und diesen Gründen machen wir das jetzt
anders.
Aber man kann nicht immer so tun, als liegt man
ultimativ richtig.
Ach ja, und dass das verfolgt, musst du gucken.
Such nach Corona.
Wie heißt der Kram?
Wie heißt diese Anwesenheitslisten?
Die bayerische Polizei macht da überhaupt keinen
Held, um dass sie das verwenden.
Ich finde es nur ein bisschen bedenklich, dass du
dadurch im Endeffekt auch Leute vielleicht ins falsche
Lager treibst.
Ich finde es nur ein bisschen bedenklich, dass du
dadurch im Endeffekt auch Leute vielleicht ins falsche
Lager treibst.
Das ist ein bisschen komplex.
Das ist ein bisschen komplex, dass man mal etwas
auch Leute vielleicht ins falsche Lager treibst, weil die sagen, hey ich glaub eh nix mehr
und dann glaub ich lieber irgendwie dem Kerl in der Telegram Gruppe, was jetzt nur für
alle nicht das ist, was man sich wünschen kann.
So, jetzt, guck mal, das ist Taktik von YouTube, wenn du ein Video angeklickt hast in einer
Position und hast es geguckt, kriegst du ein ähnliches Video an der gleichen Position
wieder.
Bayern gehört nicht zu Deutschland, ja wenn du manche Bayern fragst, ist das wirklich
so und auch wenn du manche anderen fragst, ja, die kriegen nur Mist empfohlen.
Mario Kart DS Tracks, ach ne, ich dachte das ist Mario Kart Speed Trans, da gibt es auch
richtig krasse Dinger.
Ich hab jetzt zwei Minecraft Videos angeklickt, ne und jetzt ist YouTube der Meinung, gib mir
meine Minecraft Videos, auf gehts.
Haartrockner in der Badewanne, was passiert?
Wahrscheinlich gar nix, also ich hab mir da noch nie großartig, Freunde des Stroms, das
ist ja auch mal ein geiler Channelname, man kennt das ja nur aus Filmen, so nach dem Motto,
mit einem Bein in der Badewanne, man wirft den Föhn rein und instantly komplett geschockt
und alles hinüber, wahrscheinlich passiert gar nix, vielleicht geht, vielleicht geht
auf jeden Fall der Föhn kaputt, aber das will ich mir jetzt nicht angucken, das ist
so lang, komm ich guck mal kurz rein, was passiert damit, liebe Freunde des Stroms,
ich find das schon mal ein geiler Channelname, seid ihr auch Freunde des Stroms, wie sieht
es bei euch aus, Freunde des Stroms, ja, ich spule jetzt mal ein bisschen vor, man sieht
schon Orgas Dialect, ach das ist der Föhn, aber er hat seine coole Quickscope Brille
an, die ist wichtig, also ohne die Gunner Optics Quickscope Brille geht gar nix, ok
was passiert, guck mal der Föhn, der Föhn läuft sogar noch unter Wasser weiter, ok
es passiert einfach mal gar nix, ich hätte gedacht der Föhn geht wenigstens kaputt,
jetzt mit dem gerechnet, also wir haben uns jetzt einen wunderschönen Außenbordmotor
gebaut oder, schaut euch das an, der pumpt jetzt das Wasser dadurch, natürlich der Lüfter
muss jetzt schinden, aber es passiert gar nix, im ersten Moment und jetzt werden wir
das Ganze natürlich auf elektrischer Manier einmal analysieren, aber so wie in die Krimis
ist es nicht, ich zeige es euch natürlich noch, wenn es euch interessiert, schaut euch
das an, was ist das jetzt, der Widerstand von, nee keine Ahnung, da hätte ich jetzt
vielleicht noch komplett gucken müssen, wo hält das denn dran, an die Wand, an die Wand
und?
Also das Wasser ist jetzt auch nicht isoliert, gar nix, es ist ganz normales Wasser mit Badezusatz
und bis jetzt hat noch nix ausgelöst, das ist hier, ich mache jetzt keine Werbung, aber
da ist keine Tonibox im Bad auf der Bade, Widerstand wahrscheinlich von, definitiv wieder
kracht und schäbert und dann schauen wir mal, ob man die Selektivität herhält oder
ob es wieder kommt, schauen wir mal, lassen wir uns überraschen, ich möchte jetzt noch
nix verraten.
Aha, ok, das müssen wir uns glaube ich echt ganz angucken, damit man das checkt, aber
ich will mir keine 30 Minuten Föhn in der Badewanne angucken jetzt.
Ich freu mir nicht, Stroms, how to crash Minecraft ist ganz einfach, soll ich euch zeigen, wie
man Minecraft crash?
Ich hab da gehört, es gibt da so gewisse Sachen, die man ins Chatlog schreiben kann
und dann ist vorbei, 2022 wird das Jahr für Open World Spiele, das Problem ist nur, dass
mich Open World Spiele überhaupt nicht jucken, Dying Light 2, Horizon, Elden Ring, LX2, GTA
2, Stalker, Saint Rose, Test Drive Unlimited, Solar Crown, Starfield Ark 2, Avatar, braucht
man das wirklich jetzt noch?
Irgendwie gefühlt 20 Jahre nachdem der erste Kinofilm rausgekommen ist?
Sollte es da nicht sogar einen zweiten Film geben, nicht als hätte das eine Fortsetzung
gebraucht oder so, Cyberpunk, ach schon wieder, ja gut, ja gut, bisschen Harry Potter verwursten
muss man natürlich auch noch, ja ok, das Sequel zu Breath of the Wild, das sehen wir
wahrscheinlich wenn Nintendo so weitermacht, 2030 oder so, was will denn der Switcher nochmal
hier am Start, ja gut, das kommt noch für Next Gen raus, das ist ja fast schon wie Skyrim
Alter, wie mich New World Spiele nicht interessieren, das ist der Wahnsinn, die ganze Welt geht
voll ab auf Open World, also nicht New World, sondern Open World und ich muss sagen, bis
auf ein paar Ausnahmen gehen mir Open World Spiele komplett am Arsch vorbei, also Witcher
3 war eine gute Ausnahme aber auch nur, weil es eine schlüssige Main Quest als roten Faden
gab und man quasi drum herum noch so ein bisschen spielen konnte und nicht die Open
World so als einziges da war, mit der man sich beschäftigen kann, spielt das doch einer
New World, lass doch mal gucken, naja, also ich glaube man könnte sagen, in absoluten
Zahlen gesehen, ja da spielt noch jemand, anteilmäßig könnte man sagen, es ist eigentlich
fast dead, guck mal, tolle Entwicklung, erster Monat minus 62%, nächster Monat minus 43%,
doch ich wollte am 24.
Video bringen, ich wollte mit dem Friseur ein Video aufnehmen, aber das Internet, also
Vodafone hat komplett das Internet beim Frasier abgeschaltet am 23., beste, bestes Timing,
und ab 27.
gehts angeblich wieder, was ja auch nice ist, die Leute über Weihnachten einfach mal so
hocken zu lassen, naja, mal gespannt, ob das noch klappt, ne, aber das ist Deadge und das
hier ist auch Deadge, das sind die hängengebliebenen, die sie jetzt an Weihnachten bekommen haben
und ein paar aus dem Free Weekend, guck mal, ich mein wir waren schon runter, wir waren
schon runter auf 18., guck mal, es war jetzt heilig Abend, ne, Leute, es hat sich einfach
nichts getan, niemand hat dieses Spiel zu heiliger Abend bekommen und gespielt, niemand,
jedes Sau interessiert sich dafür, so muss es auch sein, ne, hab ich noch nie, ich hab
nur bei Shroud ab und zu mal ein bisschen auf Twitch geguckt und was mich abschreckt
ist, dass das wieder so ein Game ist mit kleinteiligem Inventorymanagement, ja, ich weiß, ich weiß,
ich kenn die Videos, Belfin5 hatte gestern mehr Streamer, aber mal Steam, ah nein, ich
hab's noch nicht auf Shithub gepusht, Moment, schreib ich mir auf, GitHub, App, guck mal,
die hatten 10.000 Spieler mehr, Alter, guck mal, die hatten fast 10.000 Spieler mehr als
Battlefield 2042, das ist so schlecht und wohlgemerkt, Battlefield 5 kam auch schon nicht gut an,
wie sieht denn Battlefield, ok, das kann man jetzt schlecht vergleichen, das ist schon
so alt, es hat wahrscheinlich kaum noch einer auf Steam gekauft, ne, ok, das kannst du nicht,
das spielt auch kaum einer über Steam, mal auf Steam gucken, äh, nicht Steam, Steam Charts,
es hat fast genauso viel, ok, die Hälfte von 2042, das Problem ist, dass man das nicht
so gut vergleichen kann, weil Battlefield 20, also es ist eigentlich, es ist noch schlechter,
weil das kam von Anfang an auf Steam raus und die Games, die kamen erst mal nur auf,
also bei dem weiß ich nicht, aber die anderen kamen nur auf Origin raus und kamen jetzt
erst vor einem Jahr oder so auf Steam, also das ist, eigentlich ist es noch schlechter
vom Verhältnis, als es hier aussieht, so mies, alter, so schlecht, Wahnsinn, absolut Wahnsinn,
was die da wieder für einen Scheiß getrieben haben, naja gut, was willst du machen, die
Sache ist eh in Brunnen gefallen, da wird sich nichts mehr tun, also die werden das Spiel
nie aus dem Dreck ziehen können, neue Grafik für AMA 4, wirst du gar nicht, dass AMA 4
war, AJAJA, das fühlt sich an wie Anime Fans am Start, ok, was können wir uns jetzt angucken,
Dropping an iPhone 13, 13, 13, ja 13, Pro down, Feet, alter, ok, Feet 2 Meter, gibt's
das, ok, 487 Meter tiefer See, Kekona Freedom Units, hell yeah, Feet, wie gesagt, man könnte
es auch noch in Galonen oder in Ounces oder in Miles oder so, dann gucken wir uns das
doch jetzt mal an, also es könnte natürlich auch sein, dass es sehr langweilig ist, wenn
das permanent einfach nur runterfällt, aber so lang fällt das 480 Meter auch nicht, Will
it blend, don't try this, nee wie geht das, don't breeze this, gibt's die überhaupt
noch, Planttec YouTube, nee so wirklich machen die nichts mehr, so wirklich aktiv machen
die nicht mehr, ok gucken wir uns mal an, also lass mal überlegen, will das, überlebt
es das iPhone, ja ich denke schon, ob es noch läuft weiß ich nicht, kann man schwer sagen,
ich weiß nicht, wie wasserdicht die Dinger sind, aber ich denke mal spätestens, wenn
man das dann trocknet, geht es wieder, ich habe das Gefühl, Chat sagt, ich habe das Gefühl,
dass die Spiele sich immer weiter von den Gamern entfernt, also du meinst jetzt von dem,
was die Spieler eigentlich sich wünschen an Spielen, ja, es geht halt um Monetarisierung
und Big Stonks, nicht darum jetzt irgendwie, wo kämen wir denn dahin, wenn man die Spieler
irgendwie glücklich machen will, das will man, nein, nein, nein, nein, man möchte die
Spieler insofern glücklich genug machen, dass sie viel Geld ausgeben, aber zu happy sollen
die auch nicht sein, die sollen ja völlig den anderen Kram kaufen, so, what is up guys,
what is up, in this video we got the brand new iPhone 13 Pro, this is in pristine condition,
brand new device, guys, everything works perfectly fine, na gut, der kann sich das leisten, we
got the GoPro Hero 9 here, okay, wir gucken, ich kroll mal ein bisschen vor, wo es jetzt
eigentlich anfängt, deepest point of this lake, we're actually at Lake Tahoe, it's
one of the deepest lakes in the world and we're gonna see what happens when we send both the
GoPro in the waterproof housing in the water, okay guys, we're ready to go, ja, was ist
denn das, das ist hier die Profi-Angel, ah, wie tief das ganze ist, okay, auf gehts, auf
gehts, gib ihm, ah, by the way, dass das nur auf einer Seite ist, der Sound, das ist normal,
also mein Sound ist vollkommen okay, hör dir, auf beiden Seiten, aber das Video ist nur
left side irgendwie, das hätte er aber schöner nachbearbeiten können, ne, das hätte er
aber schöner nachbearbeiten können, ne, kann man hier vielleicht Pen oder so, Penning einstellen,
ne, kann man nicht, naja, wir brauchen ja schon einen Livestream von der GoPro, ich mein,
so ist das vielleicht ein bisschen unspektakulär, ich dachte, wir sehen jetzt, wie das da rein
fällt, also eben bei der Angel zuzugucken ist jetzt ja nur wirklich nicht sonderlich
spannend, das ist eine Angel mit Motor, das ist für Leute wie mich, die keinen Bock haben
selbst zu kurbeln, ne, dem iPhone wirst du das sicherlich nicht ansehen, ja, das habe
ich mir schon fast gedacht, also ich, ne, ne, hab ich mir nicht gedacht, ich hab mir gedacht,
das geht wahrscheinlich aus und wenn man das trocknet gehts wieder, ja ne, aber wundert
mich, wundert mich jetzt auch nicht wirklich, ach jetzt, jetzt kann man zugucken, ok, jo,
mach dir mal überhaupt gar nichts, juckt es, juckt es nicht wirklich, wobei ich sagen muss,
je nachdem wie tief die sind, ganz schön hell, oder, ganz schön hell für die, na gut, 200
Meter oder so, ich weiß nicht ab wanns richtig dunkel wird, ah jetzt wirds dunkel, ja, Leute,
das könnte natürlich jetzt so, das könnte auch aus irgendeinem Horrorfilm sein, oder,
du siehst ja nix und jetzt kommt von hinten auf einmal irgendwas großes, großes angeschwommen
so, wuhu, ich habs ja eh nicht, ich habs ja eh nicht so mit tiefem Wasser, das wisst
der, ja, guck mal jetzt ist richtig, jetzt ist richtig
ein Toaster, also zumindest wenns auf den Boden ankommt, müsste man eigentlich sehen,
sollst du dann machen blonk und auf den Boden ankomm, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ja, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ja, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
Oder ist das der Screenlock?
Ist das Handy noch am Netz?
Und kommt es jetzt unten an?
Ah, die GoPro ist kaputt?
Deswegen ging das jetzt aus.
Scheint doch nicht mehr so richtig zu funktionieren.
Siehste, das ist doch nicht angeblieben.
Das einzige was noch an ist, ist die Lampe, okay.
Aber wie gesagt, ich hätte auch vermutet das Display geht aus, aber wenn man es komplett
trocknen lässt, dann geht's wieder.
Oder der Drucker hat das Display kaputt gemacht, ja das kann natürlich auch sein.
Du musst das trocknen lassen und dann...
Okay, anscheinend geht es doch nicht mehr richtig.
Na gut, okay es geht doch nicht mehr.
Ich hätte fast vermutet, das iPhone geht noch, weil man es wieder komplett trocknen lässt
und nach Möglichkeit dann mal eine Woche liegen lässt, bis wirklich der letzte Vizel hier
an Wasser getrocknet ist und dann noch mal neu ein- und ausschaltet, äh, aus- und einschalten,
bzw.
halt mal irgendwie ein Akku abmacht oder irgendwas.
Das geht ja, wobei das geht ja nicht, muss man ja aufschreiben.
Der Drucker hat den Bildschirm kaputt gemacht, ja kann durchaus sein, Chat.
Eigentlich komplett sinnloses Video, wenn man sich mal so überlegt.
Ich mein, wozu?
Steht auf der Herstellerseite nicht ein Meter Tiefe.
Ja gut, was Hersteller so schreiben und was dann in der Realität ist, kann entweder viel
viel mehr sein oder viel viel weniger.
Bei manchen kommt es auch ungefähr hin.
Also, making was?
A drone with Lego Motor.
Das soll funktionieren?
Ist das Lego Motor Zeug nicht viel zu schwer?
Also, das war immer so mein Traum, wie ich klein war.
Ich hab ja auch viel Lego Technik gebastelt.
Ich hatte auch so einen fetten Lego Motor und hatte auch ein paar Propeller und sonst
was.
Das höchste der Gefühle, was ich geschafft hab, ist ein Schiff, was fahren konnte mit
Propeller und ein, da hatte ich so ein Brett gebaut, das war ja nicht wirklich ein Schiff,
also so ein Brett mit Lego Motor drauf, was man dann so minimalsteuern konnte.
Aber ansonsten, dass das abhebt, habe ich so meine Zweifel, wobei, je nachdem, was es
für neue Lego Motoren gibt, ach so, der betreibt es auch nicht mit dem normalen Lego Motor
Motor, sondern der benutzt nur den Lego Motor und dann ein ordentliches Netzteil für.
Okay, ja, dann könnte ich mir das natürlich vorstellen, dass das doch funktionieren könnte.
Was hat er da unten drunter stehen, ach, das ist eine Waage, oder, das ist eine Waage,
dass er gucken kann, wie viel hebt das Ding hoch.
Der L-Motor ist der Mehr-Pepo-Fett.
Gleich geht's durch die Decke, okay, Minus, Minus ist schon mal gut, das ist nice, okay,
das heißt, wenn er so eine Drohne baut, wenn er davon jetzt vier Stück nimmt, dann muss
er das Ding ungefähr, sag mal, der Rest darf maximal 200 Gramm zusätzlich wiegen, dass
es noch funktioniert, am besten deutlich weniger, weil ansonsten wird es halt mit dem Fliegen
ein bisschen eklig, ach, gucken wir mal, Stress-Test, na gut, dass die Lego kaputt geht, denke ich
mal nicht, aber ob es am Ende abhebt, habe ich trotzdem so meine Zweifel, ich meine,
da muss ja noch Steuerung dran, da müssen Akkus dran, also sprich, da muss irgendwie
die Akkus dran bekommen und das alles, sagen wir mal, sollte unter 150 Gramm zusammenwiegen,
Akkus, Steuerung, alles, Kabel, was auch immer man braucht, das sollte alles unter 150 Gramm,
das müssen wir mal wiegen, sonst fliegt es halt nicht gescheit, ach, Moment, der braucht
ja zwei, der braucht zwei Motoren, die sich links rumdrehen und zwei, die sich rechts
rumdrehen, dass die Drohne nicht so einen Trall hat, im Kreis sich zu drehen, oder,
oder warum braucht der zwei in die Richtung, zwei in die Richtung, nee, das funktioniert
so nicht, das wackelt, das bounce ja, das ist ihm aber voll, das bounce ja wie verrückt
rum, ok, dann hat er insgesamt noch weniger, also da muss er auf jeden Fall unter 150 Gramm
zusätzliche noch bleiben, sonst hebt das Ding nicht ab, Big Brain Lego Skills, ah,
der gute Wackeltest, oh nee, das wird so nichts, ah, yes, weiß aber nicht, wie gut das dann
funktioniert, wenn sich das überlagert, macht das bestimmt ein bisschen größer, ja, ja,
gib ihm, ja, viel besser gleich, viel besser, wenn sich das nicht überlappt, ok, das heißt,
der muss jetzt, ok, ok, mal langsam, also der muss jetzt den Rest Akkus und Verkabelung
und Steuerung, muss unter 125 Gramm sein, dass das Ding abhebt, wobei es sollte eine
ganze Ecke unter 125 Gramm sein, also was weiß ich, unter 100 Gramm, aber allein schon
die Akkus dürften über 120, da bin ich mal gespannt was da rauskommt, na gut, oder es
sind halt welche mit nicht viel Ladung, was ist denn so ein normaler Drohnen Akku, ich
hab keine Ahnung ehrlich gesagt, was fährt man da normalerweise, 800 milliampere Stunden
oder, ich hab keinen Schimmer, ich hab da mich null mit beschäftigt bisher, eine runde
Transistor, jetzt wird es gesteckt, PWM Signal für die, ach, das ist der Controller für
die Lüfter, ok, PWM Signal braucht man für die Steuerung vom, warum hat er nochmal, warum
hat er nochmal, ah, ok, das ist PWM Signal, 3,3 Volt vom Controller an den Transistor
und da drüber gehen dann bis zu 55 Volt, ok, der Controller wird mit anderer Spannung
betrieben logischerweise als der Motor, passt ja auch, klingt ja irgendwie logisch, das
heißt er braucht das PWM Signal, nimmt damit, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, vom Controller
mit 3 Volt als Input und der Transistor gibt das dann irgendwie weiter, das PWM Signal,
ok, warte mal, boah, was ist das für Big Brain Software, ach, der Controller hat auch
automatisch gleich so einen, wie nennt man das, so einen Accelerator oder was auch immer
Sensor mit eingebaut, dass du weißt, wie das gerade liegt und wie es beschleunigt und
sonst was, Lage Controller, ok, ja, aha, jetzt flutscht es, das hat mir der Chat beigebracht,
ich wusste gar nicht, dass man das mit nem Teppichmesser abschneiden kann, könnt ihr
euch noch, falls da jemand dabei war von euch, ich hab mich ja auch mal gefragt, wie ich
so ein paar Platten abkriege, dann meint der Chat, nehm einfach Teppichmesser und schneide
zweimal durch und brechst es dann ab und was hab ich gemacht, zweimal mit dem Messer drüber
und abgebrochen und es hat funktioniert, richtig Expanded Brain vom Chat wieder gewesen.
Und das, wenns fertig ist, warum bohrt der da Löcher rein, hat niemand, warum bohrt
der da Löcher rein, ach Leiterbahn unterbrechen, ok, exzellent, exzellent, bohr, das ist ja
die halbe Rolle, lützchen, warum du pink bist, weil das random im Chat ist, also in
dem Anzeige Chat, ok, 4 Stück, weil 4 Motoren vermute ich mal, das ist ja so ein bisschen
der Unterschied zwischen Drohnen oder sag mal mal auch so Spielzeughelis und echten Helikoptern,
bei echten Helikoptern hast du ja in der Regel das, also wie stark der sinkt und steigt,
machst du ja bei echten Helis mit dem Anstellwinkel quasi der Rotorblätter und bei Drohnen machst
du es über die Drehgeschwindigkeit der Motoren, ich mein wisst ihr was das coole ist im Jahr
2021, dass es schon für ein Appel und ein Ei solche fertigen Controller gibt, wo du
eigentlich nix machen musst außer den Kram anlöten und vielleicht irgendwie Firma drauf
flaschen, Pog, ah ja klar, er muss das Ding ja irgendwie fernsteuern, kommt das Xbox,
das Xbox Gamepad, ok jetzt muss er das wahrscheinlich irgendwie peern, dass das ordentlich funktioniert,
also das ganze Zeug was er da jetzt baut muss unter 100 Gramm wiegen, inklusive Akkus, sonst
hebt das Ding nicht gescheit ab und ich weiß nicht wie dieser Effekt heißt, aber man darf
sich da nicht jebaiten lassen, also überm Boden erzeugt das Ding mehr Auftrieb als höher
in der Luft, da gibt es irgendwie so ein, frag mich nicht, da gibt es irgendwie so einen
speziellen Turbulenzen, Verwirbelungseffekt irgendwie, also du brauchst quasi weniger
Power knapp überm Boden, wie wenn du hochfliegst, deswegen kann das sein, dass es quasi abhebt
und dann direkt wieder runterfällt, wenn es zu schwer ist, ah ja Obvious, SC, na klar,
Verlängerungskabel, bin mir da gar nicht so sicher, ab einer gewissen Höhe ist wahrscheinlich
so ein Verlängerungskabel genauso schwer und ab einer gewissen Höhe ein Verlängerungskabel
noch schwerer als die Akkus, weil das wiegt ja auch was, wobei ich weiß nicht, 100 Gramm
Kabel, wieviel Meter sind das, Power Offer Wifi müsste das betreiben, genau, da braucht
man gar keine Akkus mehr, naja, ok, das wird aber, das wird, ok, 50 Gramm für die Akkus,
das sein Controller und Kabelzeug wird wahrscheinlich auch nochmal 10-15 Gramm wiegen, da bleibt
er auf jeden Fall, also das Ding kann zumindest potenziell abheben, ey man soll da nicht krasse
Flugeigenschaften, wenn wir das jetzt nicht haben, das ist richtig geil, dass es sowas
schon als kostenlose Software beziehungsweise für kleines Geld gibt an Controller und Software
als mega Poggers, ich hab davon keinen Plan, also ich hab mich nie mit Drohnen großartig
beschäftigt, aber ist schon geil, oh, das sieht schon besser aus, so, das ist das was
ich meine, wenn der, wenn der, ich hab, wie gesagt, ich hab keine Ahnung, da gibt es
irgend so ein Effekt, gibt es auch bei Helis und so, wenn der so knapp über den Boden
fliegt, braucht der weniger Auftrieb um zu fliegen, als wenn er hoch fliegt, weil es
irgendwie, weil es einmal, glaube ich, Auftrieb erzeugt durch das Luft durchziehen und dann
weil die Luft von unten vom Boden quasi abprallt und nochmal, also du brauchst weniger, Beta
Flight auf GitHub, Beta Flight, ah ja, nice, guck mal da, Beta Flight, nicht Sigma Flight,
es ist Beta Flight, nice, hier, das meine ich Leute, das meine ich, hier, der Bodeneffekt,
als Bodeneffekt bezeichnet man ein physikalisches Phänomen, das ein umströmter Körper in Bodennähe
erfährt, jeweils kann je nach Form des umströmten Körpers zusätzlicher dynamischer Auftrieb
oder auch Abtrieb entstehen, alles klar, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid, noted, ah jetzt muss
er den Kram noch kalibrieren, dass das überall gleichermaßen stabil bleibt, ok, das sieht
schon viel besser aus jetzt, ey, das könnte wirklich funktionieren, ne, wahrscheinlich
funktioniert es, als hätte er das Video nicht gemacht, auf der anderen Seite, auch wenn
es nicht funktioniert, ist das trotzdem ein Video, das viele Leute angucken, das sieht
erstaunlich gut aus, was hat er denn jetzt, ich hab jetzt gar nicht geguckt, was hat er
denn jetzt für Akkus, oh, oh, boah, guck, dann sieht man es, sobald er ein bisschen
vom Boden wegfliegt, hat das Ding ordentliche Probleme hochzukommen, ah, mehr Power, ok,
33 Volt, was sind das für welche, weiß man nicht, kann man das kalibrieren, auch wenn
die Gewichtsverteilung nicht optimal ist, ja genau dafür ist es da denke ich mal, ja
viel besser Klai, ja viel besser, oh, und zack, pock, oh, rip, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
lopass, ja
Funktioniert erstaunlich gut, oh jetzt muss es fein, da ist sehr wenig Platz für die
Größe der Drohne und so super ruhig liegt die ja auch nicht in der Luft, also das stelle
ich mir schwer vor, rums, das wird nichts, ein bisschen mehr Platz, aber cool das es
überhaupt funktioniert, ja, schon nice, da habe ich immer davon geträumt, wie ich klein
war mal irgendwas mit Lego Motor zu bauen, das was fliegen kann, man muss ja sagen, es
ist natürlich nicht pur Lego, allein schon die Akkus und das Teilstrom herum ist nichts,
was du mit Lego alleine bauen konntest, aber ist schon nice, kannst du den Videolink, du
meinst das hier, ja, Org, funktioniert, oh was hat es gekostet, guck mal ist gar nicht
so teuer, guck mal der Controller 22 Euro und der Empfänger für den Controller nochmal
20 Euro, also du bist mit 40 Euro für so ein Steuerungs Ding dabei und 7 Euro für
den Astronaut, ja, ah der Controller und die Batterien, ja gut, die Akku Packs, 200
mAh, ok, lange fliegt die Drohne aber nicht, oh ok, also ein Schnapper ist es nicht gerade,
da kriegt man mit Sicherheit bessere und günstigere Drohne, aber es geht ja auch darum, dass es
geht, jo nice, die 9 Stück sind zusammen wie ein kleiner Handyakku, nee, die sind bestimmt
nicht parallel betrieben oder, oder doch, nee, wie kommt er sonst auf 33,3 Volt, was
hat er für Akkus, Akkus, ach hier sind die Akku Packs, naja, aber cool, dass das funktioniert,
nicht übel, hätt ich am Anfang nicht gedacht ehrlich gesagt, dass das funktioniert, Battlefield
2042, aber wenn du Battlefield ausmachst, sobald du eine Cringe-Voice-Line hörst, dann
ist ja quasi direkt nach Start aus, ja, oh, das ist der schlimmste Spruch im ganzen Game,
und Spiel ausschalten, ja, komm mal, jetzt haben wir ein Lego-Video geguckt, jetzt kriegen
wir nur noch Lego-Videos empfohlen, der YouTube-Algorithmus ist bei der Arbeit, der Drachenlord versagt
erneut bei Mario 64, ist der nicht im Gefängnis, ich dachte der muss ins Gefängnis, hab ich
irgendwas mitbekommen, was ist denn da rausgekommen jetzt, ich hab, ich kann mich noch an das
Gerichtsurteil erinnern, dass er irgendwie ins Gefängnis muss, oh, aber anscheinend
doch nicht, aha, geht noch weiter, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok,olui, jetzt abdomen, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,ok, ok, mal schauen, mal schauen,
Das brauchen wir nicht
Okay, was gucken wir uns als nächstes an schuldinge die ich nie verstanden habe das ist wieder das summa video haben wir uns letzten schon
was angeguckt
Und das sind nur drei minuten 43. Mal gucken ob ich ob ich
die summa high speed schnitte dieses mehr aushalten
Nach all meinen jahren schule gibt es immer noch einiges dass ich einfach nie verstanden haben eines davon ist wer hat sich die regeln ausgedacht
Und verbreitet dass wenn lehrer nach 15 minuten nicht das ist schwachsinn hause gehen dürfte
Das ist das das haben die bei mir schon in der schule erzählt aber das ist halt komplett das schwachsinn allein schon aus
haftungstechnischen gründen kann das nicht funktionieren sollten schulden so eine regel haben jedes mal gab es bei mir immer irgendjemanden der nach fünf minuten meinte
Jo leute noch zehn minuten dann dürfen wir gehen ja ja das ist die regel glaubt mir einfach und falls das jemand von euch auch noch glaubt
Sorry schwachsinn die regel ist ja das ist ich meine jeder der nur irgendwie fünf gehirnzellen im kopf hat sollte eigentlich auf die idee kommen
Dass das bescheuert ist aber das haben die bei mir auch erzählt
Ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich glaube bei mir waren sogar noch zehn minuten wenn zehn minuten keiner kommt oder so
Wir hatten es auch ein paar mal da kann ich mich noch daran erinnern
Wir hatten es auch ein paar mal dass sie lehrer wirklich nicht gekommen sind und
Dann sind die da sind die leute dann runter ins
Beim lehrerzimmer und da wusste dann auch keiner wo das steckt
Und da durften wir in in diesen pausenraum gehen für die stunde ja das ist ein paar mal passiert ich weiß bis heute nicht was mit dem los war
Wir hatten die ultra fertige lehrer also unsere chemie lehrerin die hat permanent gezittert
Und nachher habe ich auch rausgekriegt warum die hat sich halt öfters mal ein bisschen zu viel gegönnt
Das ist dann später rausgekommen und ein lehrer bei uns hat sich umgebracht
Das fand ich damals mega schockierend
Aber ein lehrer der hat der hatte bei uns auch den informatik kann man es nicht nicht nennen
computer kurs sagen wir mal der hat sich umgebracht
Sagen wir mal der hat sich umgebracht und das fand ich damals richtig schockierbar ist es ja im prinzip auch du rechtest ja mit nix
Und auf einmal kriegst du morgens erzählt hier übrigens euer lehrer hat sich umgebracht
Das war schon heftig geschichte damals
Ja genau so war das so war das bei uns auch
Man ist dann man ist dann in zum lehrerzimmer gegangen und dann wurde geguckt was halt witzig war
Was halt was halt witzig war bei uns dass
Die im lehrerzimmer nicht mal wussten wo der typ war
Also wir hatten so ein üblichen üblichen verdächtigen also es war eigentlich immer der gleiche der zu spät gekommen ist
Erst mal nach zehn minuten zum lehrerzimmer und hat gefragt wie es ist und da wusste auch keiner wo der ist
Hat sich irgendwo abgeseilt zwischendurch und keiner wusste wo er steckt
Tja
In den 2000 auch verständlich warum in den 2000er war die welt noch in ordnung
Wünschte es wäre war ich dachte auch immer die blaue seite von diesen radier gummys wäre zum tinte radieren da
Das das dachte ich nie aber ich das dachte ich tatsächlich nie aber ich weiß bis heute nicht wofür die blaue seite der radier gummys eigentlich da ist
Es funktioniert nicht also wer hat sich auch diese lüftung
Es funktioniert nicht also wer hat sich auch diese lüge ausgedacht und für was ist es sonst da ja anscheinend ist es wirklich für tinte
Ah cool merke ich bei klassenarbeiten war es bei mir auch immer mit tinte quatsch ernsthaft
Ich habe da nicht auf die ich bin noch nie auf die idee gekommen da tinte für das kannst du noch mit keine tinte mit weg machen
Aber wofür die blaue seite bei radieren da ist habe ich auch nicht verstanden
Die lehrer haben ewig gebraucht um sie zu korrigieren und meinten zu uns immer so ja ihr seid ja noch in der mittelstufe
Ich muss zuerst die elften und zwölften korrigieren die machen gerade abitur ist viel wichtiger und ich denke mir ok ok ergibt
Den doch sobald ich selbst in den abiturklassen bin heißt es hier ich bin klassenlehrer ja ich muss ich muss so viel von den unteren
Stufen noch
Das ist einfach das ist halt einfach ausrede ja
Das spielchen also und wieso machen lehrer auch das so oft sie sind am pc sie machen einen filmen und setzen sich nach hinten und lassen den
Mauszeiger durch geht mitten im bild wie jetzt
Sehen sie das nicht wo ist das problem was macht man in der situation soll ich jetzt mittendrin nach vorne ich sehe das problem nicht
Dann werden wir alle wohl ein müssen irgendwann hat jemand von mir einfach einen normalen vortrag halten
Ihr wisst wilder benutzt freigesprochen deswegen kommt am ende natürlich
Ihr wisst hand andere hand klatsch der klassiker doch plapper ich aus dem nicht haben alle ab da statt zu klatschen auf den tisch
Geklopft ja das verstehe ich auch nicht warum
Das das habe ich bis heute auch das habe ich bis heute nicht verstanden
Macht ihr das nicht ein bisschen falsch oder habe ich irgendwas verpasst habe nie krank will einer von euch erklären dass ihr abgeht
Habs ab da nicht mehr hinterfragt und ab da auch immer gemacht ich verstehe es immer noch nicht zum nächsten ding französisch
Ein anderes ding sind glami patrouille wieso jemand fragt hey hat ihr mit einer tinten patrouille wisst ihr was ich nicht verstehe
Warum schreibt man warum kann man nicht einfach mit bleistift mit mit bleistift oder mit kulli schreiben warum braucht man so ein so ein krab wie füller
Von handschreiben eigentlich heutzutage noch ich freibildlich wie ich bin haben natürlich eine parat hier hier
Aha dank oh nee nicht so eine ich brauche eine lami patrouille warum hat lami eigene tinten patrouille formen
Warum passen die normalen weil weil wenn du lock in
Nicht rein die sind sogar kleiner was ich auch nicht verstehe die märchen ihr sitzt im klassenraum rum der lehrer kommt rein und kommt mit diesen
Dingern an erstens was ist das überhaupt und zweitens warum existieren die man kriegt ein testschreib
Ach das ist so ein sicht schutzdinger
Da steht immer irgendwas drauf warum gehen bleistift aus rechtlichen gründen nicht wenn ich in der klasse
Sitze und mal also bei arbeiten kann ich ja noch verstehen aber wenn ich in der klasse sitze und dort was aufschreibe kann ich das doch machen mit was ich will
Und bei uns wollten sie auch immer dass man das mit füller schreibt was ziemlich bescheuert war aber gerade bleistift
Müsste funktionieren
Ablenkt und das design ist irgendwie und wenn ich wirklich abschreiben wollen würde könnte man ja trotzdem
Manchmal blockiert genau das teilt sicht zum lehrer entweder es gibt einen guten lehrer rabatt oder sie hat krasse special lehrer funktionen alles kann ich mir nicht erklären warum jeder lehrer diese tasche hat und wo wir bei taschen sind ich hatte bis zur sechsten klasse noch so einen schuhranzen
Ich hatte ich hatte ein east pack in east pack rucksack und die ganzen die ganzen coolen leute
Die haben bei uns immer weiß nicht ob man das heutzutage noch so macht east pack logo
Die haben die haben das so übermalt dass dann also sie haben halt die haben quasi hier das das das e und das t übermalt dass dann asi pack drauf stande richtig richtig pains jam
Das da war man cool damals wenn man das gemacht hat man hat einfach einen schwarzen adding genommen hat das e weggemacht und das t und dann war das asi pack
Genau das hier genau das genau das ja oder hat man sie richtig nice gefühlt weil asi pack hatte
Während alle anderen nach der zeit schon auf rucksäcke gewechselt sind
Es ist nicht mehr cool es funktioniert doch noch einwandfrei was anderes was mich verwirrt so ein klassen frühstück
Also rucksäcke rucksäcke waren bei uns auch so ein ding also ich hatte ich hatte immer rucksäcke also ne in der grundschule nicht aber ich hatte immer rucksäcke und ich habe heute noch einen rucksack weil ich rucksäcke einfach praktisch finde aber irgendwann haben die leute bei uns dann angefangen so coole umhängetaschen so hipster umhängetaschen zu haben
Hipster umhängetasche
Ne ne ne ne nicht sowas okay hipster soll ich vielleicht weglassen
Die leute hatten dann so coole so was da in der richtung die hatten dann alle so coole umhängetaschen nur noch
Und ich hab den sinn und die daseinsberechtigung von umhängetaschen bis heute noch nicht verstanden wenn man doch einfach einen rucksack anziehen kann
Die bammelt nicht rum die ist nicht im weg ein rucksack passt mehr rein wo ist der sinn von einer umhängetasche
Wer von euch sich die mühe macht 60 brötchen zu kaufen um sie um acht uhr in die schule mitzunehmen also versteht mich nicht falsch ich bin dir auf ewig dankbar dass du uns für das team einsetzt und opferst oder deine eltern aber bro es gibt viel leichtere jobs
Käse Brotaufschnitt Marmelade Obst ich hab zum beispiel zum klassen frühstück immer wasser mitgenommen
wasser mitgenommen wasser perfekt
Marmelade ist halt auch easy stell sie drei kleser hin und gut ist
Wasser
Warum benutzen manche lehrer noch Overheadprojektoren vor allem wenn direkt
Weil warum wohl
Weil boomer lehrer weil sonst ich hätte es nicht für möglich gehalten dass leute 2021 noch in der schule sitzen und lehrer Overheadprojektoren verwenden
Ich fand die dinger 1998 schon kacke
Aber zwar über 20 jahre später muss man sich den kram immer noch ergeben
Da hinter ihnen ein pc mit bima steht ein pc macht nicht geräusche als würde das gleich
Na bima bima ist ja für die also pc und bima ist ja nur wirklich für die meisten lehrer komplettes teufel zeug ich stelle mir das ähnlich vor
Bei uns hatten die lehrer damals probleme video recorder zu bedienen dann kam die dann mit dem fernsehwagen um die ecke und da musste immer der schleimer vom dienst vorne zum lehrer hin und dem helfen den video recorder einzuschalten
Weil die unfähig waren dafür so
Und
Heute ist es wahrscheinlich so dass
Projektor projektor und pc das abgelöst hat und dann auch der schleimer vom dienst vorne hin muss und dem lehrer helfen den film zu starten auf dem pc warum können lehrer eigentlich das was man für ihre tägliche arbeit braucht nicht
Na ja
Was dein lehrer hat den aufwärtsprojektor per camera auf teams übertragen oh ja das ist da besonders tolle qualität gewesen dann
Na gut schulpc sind tatsächlich mulatt
Man muss das nicht so komisch scharf stellen man kann jedes arbeitsblatt einfach direkt anzeigen das einzige was man machen muss ist den bima einzuschalten
Oh
Und wie es für mich war bei solchen lehrern während der online unterrichtszeit mein abitur schulabschluss zu machen das hat er schon erzählt ja
Die Zeit war wirklich weird
Weird champ
Jetzt haben wir uns schon zwei videos von ihm angeguckt das heißt ich kriege jetzt hier die youtube youtube algorithm schlägt schlägt wieder zu
Was ohne witz unser fernsehen hat damals nicht funktioniert und meine geschichtslehrerin hat ernsthaft gesagt kann man das nicht mit einer pdf verknüpfen
Ich wüsste bei dieser aussage noch nicht mal was sie eigentlich meint
Gibt es gibt es eigentlich schulpc die schon abgegradet sind auf windows 10 oder laufen die alle noch mit windows xp
Windows 3 1 ist es nicht mehr aber
Die laufen bestimmt alle mit windows xp
Schon auf vista immerhin
Ja linux ist auch nicht verkehrt da ganz ehrlich in der schule je nachdem was man braucht ist da eine linux installation gar nicht so blöde drauf
Wenn man nur also was weiß ich wenn man nur im internet gucken will oder irgendwie die ein oder anderen office dokumente machen will warum nicht
Eine linux geschichte drauf das muss kein win noch sein was auch den großen vorteil hat du fängst dir nicht irgendeinen scheiß ein
Ist das nur in deutschland so mit technik ja in kolumbien ist es besser
Das geht das geht doch sogar noch ich meine kann durchaus schlimmer sein
Internet explorer
Also ich weiß noch in der berufsschule in der berufsschule da hat der lehrer so eine eigene remote steuerung software selbst programmiert allein schon das ist eine
Sehr merkwürdige idee gewesen zumindest war dieses ding
Etwas verbackt der hatte das war relativ simpel
Der hatte quasi auf jedem rechner einen agent installiert und vorne hat er halt so ein steuerungs ding gehabt da konnte er auch die bildschirme sperren per knopfdruck
Aber du konntest ohne problemen diese software beenden nicht weil du rechte dazu hat das das haben sie geschickt gemacht also hat es nicht die rechte die software zu binden aber
Du konntest einfach in telnet machen telnet localhost port was weiß ich 5050 weil die software auf 5050 lief
Und dann hast du einfach telnet gemacht auf 5050 und hast irgendeinen random shit reingeschrieben
Und die software war nicht in der lage random shit zu verarbeiten ist gecrashed und dann konnte er den rechner nicht mal sperren und war immer höchst verwirrt
Arch by the way ja so ist es
Wie nicht archlinux warum archlinux ist das einzig wahre da kann man nämlich der ganzen welt erzählen dass man beide bei archlinux by the way verwendet
Ach cmd ist gesperrt bei den schulrechnern das ist aber schwierig in einer lage
In einer fachinformatiker ausbildungsklasse weil dann brauchst du manchmal die cmd für dinger
Archlinux was archlinux ist archlinux ist by the way archlinux das beste linux was es gibt by the way
Archlinux ist eine linux distribution für absolute hackermans wird nur noch getoppt durch gendu alles selbst kompilieren
Oder linux vom scratch drei monate bauen und dann nicht am end nicht mehr aktualisieren können
Also ich glaube archlinux by the way wird bloß nicht mehr aktualisieren
Also ich glaube archlinux by the way wird bloß noch von gendu selbst kompilieren getoppt
Ja wir hatten in der berufsschule auch die üblichen geschichten drauf cs dungeon keeper hatten wir noch drauf
Durfte man zwar offiziell nicht spielen hat man aber trotzdem gemacht das war dann immer so das kann man daran erinnern stunde ist vorbei stunde ist vorbei
Und man hat gesagt wir sind nicht ganz fertig geworden können wir die pause über hier in dem raum brauche in dem raum bleiben wenn die nächsten kommen gehen wir raus
Und haben die lehrer eigentlich in der regel immer gesagt ja ja macht ruhig in ruhe fertig ich lasse euch auf
Und da haben die da sind vorne an den plan haben raufgeguckt okay nächste stunde ist hier ist hier klasse xy drinne
Und sowieso lehrer passt ok
Und da haben wir dann quasi zeug gespielt in der pause lehrer hat natürlich gedacht wir mal wobei ganz ehrlich lehrer sind ja auch nicht blöd
Wir haben gesagt wir wollen das zeug fertig machen dem war klar dass wir irgendwas spielen die sind ja auch nicht dumm
Die wussten bloß ok
Hauptsache sie können es offiziell abstreiten dass sie davon wussten
Die wussten bloß ok das hauptsache sie können es offiziell abstreiten dass sie davon wussten
Richtig hackermans kompilieren alles selbst das ist stellt euch mal vor soll es richtig krass agent du hacker man
Ihr bekommt eine mail geschickt mit einem open office dokument im anhang da müsst ihr erst mal fünf stunden open office kompilieren
Oder chrome leute hat mal jemand ernsthaft von euch chrome selber kompiliert
Wisst ihr eigentlich wie lang das dauert wie kompliziert das ist und wie viel ram und plattenplatz das braucht
Du brauchst da irgendwie keine ahnung 60 gigabit nach geht es übertrieben du brauchst da schon
16 16 g ram 80 80 g festplatte und es läuft trotzdem zwei stunden
Also chrome selber kompilieren ist glaube ich das schlimmste was man machen kann
Also wir hatten nur ein lehrer der selbst was gespielt hat
Und der hat immer während der stunde während die leute was gemacht haben hat er immer world of warcraft forum gesurft vorne am rechner
Der hat world of warcraft gebrauchst die halbe stunde
Ja wahrscheinlich reicht es wahrscheinlich reicht es für chrome auch nicht ich habe jetzt einfach mal 16 g gesagt das kannst du knicken
Hey day auf dem ipad was ist denn hey day
Irgendein casual casual game oder
Or farmbild ein farmbild clone oh meine güte
Der war kurz afk
Was ist das dachte in overwatch geschichte
Na ja so was können wir uns als nächstes geben
Zeigst mal her
Nochmal eine chance youtube
Nein kündigung bei ubisoft ja das sind eh so dreck säcke ne ist jetzt super ist eine super geschichte wir kündigen einfach mal eine woche vor weihnachten was ein scheißladen oder
Ich weiß einfach mal leute vor weihnachten raus wahrscheinlich macht es dann macht sich dann besser im jahresabschluss oder so
Oder sind die leute selbst weg gerannt ach andersrum die leute sind ihn abgehauen
Ach sehr noch besser ok dann ist gut dann ist gut in den würde ich wünschen dass alle leute wegrennen
Alle weg
Scheißladen ja die haben sich besser verdient ich hoffe blizzard rennen auch die ganzen leute weg
Ihr habt ubisoft azubis in der klasse poc was ubisoft hat fisi azubis
Ok nice warum nicht
Ja 50 Milliarden lang ist schon huge
So also was kommt jetzt an was ist das
Budget storage server 2021 ist das aus dem kokona land
Wenn es nämlich aus dem kokona land ist dann ist das für uns nicht wirklich übertragbar
Weil die haben es nicht so mit strompreisen
Bei den amis sind die strompreise viel billiger
Ich frage mich immer was die alle machen ich mein 80 terabyte
Ich nehme ja auch ein bisschen gameplay auf und sowas dass ich was dass ich was habe für für zukünftige videos aber ich wüsste gar nicht
Wo ich achte wofür ich 80 terabyte für als als content creator für content bräuchte
Na ja das teure dabei sind ja eh die festplatten
Bei so einer also bei so einer kapazität sind das teure die festplatten und die festplatten kosten gleich viel ob ich sie jetzt in den zynology reinpacke oder ob ich die jetzt in
Keine ahnung meine bei ebay gekaufte 2h e-kiste mache 80 terabyte wenn man davon ausgeht der nimmt 10 terabyte platten das sind 18 terabyte platten das kostet 4000 euro die platten so über den daumen gepeilt
Ungefähr 4000 euro für die platten muss ausgeben da macht der macht das preis für so ein einsteiger zynology oder irgendwie macht der da auch nicht so fett
sind das 80 terabyte ohne redundanz oder backups das ist die frage keine ahnung wenn das 80 terabyte nach irgendwelchen rate geschichten sind braucht er ja noch viel mehr platten müssen wir uns angucken keine ahnung
Keine ahnung das problem ist dass die platten so teuer sind genau genau das ist das problem
Okay 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 okay wie ich gesagt habe 8 terabyte mal 10 oder halt ne ich habe gesagt 8 mal 10 und er hat 10 mal 8 aber das ist trotzdem das kostet wahrscheinlich trotzdem irgendwie 4000 pro ne ne ne wobei 8 ich glaube 8 8 terabyte sind günstiger
günstiger oh was okay 200 euro oh ein paar amazon
180 euro also 180 mal 8 ne ach mal 10 ja das ist gut das muss ich dann rechnen also ungefähr 2000 euro für platten was kostet eine 18 t platte 18 tb
das ist richtig günstig geworden warum ist das denn so günstig amazon ich habe meine ich habe vor zwei jahren oder so eine 12 terabyte platte gekauft und die hat glaube ich noch 400 euro gekostet oder so
sack orders das ist rausch liegt am handy z gate glaube ich war das noch z gate z gate 10 tb ne das ist die falsche was haben wir sonst noch anstatt z gate haben wir noch wd ne wd stopp wd habe ich gekauft nicht ed alter autocorrekt autocorrekt auf dem handy wd
wd interne platte ne dies von 2000 disc disc alter warum ist die suche bei amazon eigentlich so scheiße dass du nichts findest fest platte hier 10 tb
es ist aber die falsche ich habe 12 tb aber hier sind aber 10 10 10 tb die hat die hat schon gekostet oder details 2017 hat die 400 euro gekostet 400 euro für eine 10 tb platte das ist tatsächlich relativ günstig geworden
durchaus in ordnung das das das geht ja direkt gucken wir mal geizhals kurz
es gibt schon 20 terabyte es gibt sogar schon 20 t massive was ist die größte festplatte die es aktuell gibt 96 ja aber guck mal 447 ach ne moment
ein bisschen laut die musik lull warum ist das doch
hä hier hard drives so gucken wir mal ok 20 ah da sind wir schon in anderen preisregionen ok ok das sind 24 euro pro terabyte und wie sieht es aus bei den
18 auf viel viel günstiger alter pok champ so jetzt machen wir das mal raus und jetzt sortieren wir mal alles nach preis preis pro terabyte ok die günstigsten sind anscheinend wirklich
die günstigsten sind anscheinend wirklich 14 14 terabyte 18 ne mit mit einer der günstigsten sind die hier guck mal 18 terabyte sind die mit dieser fake plattenüberlagerungsmagnetechnik oder ist das normal mit mehr platten drinne
exos enterprise ja das ist eigentlich gar nicht schlecht ich meine mal ernsthaft 300 euro das ist das ist durchaus ok
equipper hat schon mal jemand bei equipper bestellt a mine factory nur 309 euro ich bin ich bin geneigt mir da sogar eine zu bestellen
ja nice egal gucken wir das video mal weiter also aber auch was man hier sieht trotzdem die festplattenpreise sind wahrscheinlich das entscheidende
relativ gut das ding braucht wahrscheinlich massig strom weil es relativ alte server hat wer von ebay ist
was hast du den shitstorm wegen dem neuen arch lilux wiki layout bekommen ne schauen wir mal wie ist denn das neue layout
ist das ist das schmaler geworden im vergleich zu sonst ansonsten sieht das doch mehr oder weniger noch exakt so aus wie vorher
außer dass es glaube ich ein bisschen schmaler ist dann sieht man es eh besser mit boomeraugen und schon hat man die ganze seite wieder ausgefüllt
man hätte einfach gucken können wenn die geräte groß sind dann macht man das breiter das ist halt das ist halt das ding wenn man mobile first
macht heißt ja nicht dass man desktop last machen muss man kann ja mobile first und desktop first machen es gibt ja media queries
kannst du einfach sagen wenn gerät größer ist als also man braucht ja diesen diesen mist gar nicht so zu machen das ist auf dem fetten desktop
weil es gibt ja mal ehrlich gesagt es gibt ja überhaupt keinen grund warum auf dem desktop das nur die hälfte des bildschirms verwenden sollte
einfach ein media query gemacht und gesagt hey bildschirm ab einer gewissen größe einfach das hier größer machen ich meine so schwer kann das ja nicht sein
page main content main content so wo stehts hier max width 80 so schwer wäre das jetzt da nicht eine media query zu machen was das hier macht oder
oder oder oder sah das jetzt super komplex aus das zu implementieren
HI
ich könnte sogar noch weiter gehen und sagen 100 prozent das geht nicht ok jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich geprägt
Jetzt hab ich's geprägt.
Nee, aber ihr wisst, ihr seht, was ich meine, also an sich, an sich gar kein Problem.
Okay, jetzt wird's durch was anderes limitiert, aber es wär kein Ding gewesen, sowas einzubauen,
wirklich nett.
Die Seite ist besser lesbar, wenn sie schmal ist, naja, also da kann man sich jetzt wirklich
drüber streiten, also ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wo das Sinn sein sollte, zu sagen, hey, du
hast zwar einen fetten Bildschirm, aber wir benutzen nur die Hälfte.
So, gucken wir, gucken wir doch mal, ob das stimmt, ob das schlechter, wir gucken jetzt
mal, ob das stimmt, ob das schlechter lesbar ist, wenn ich das jetzt überscale, 100, nee,
ich bin falsch, oder, so, guck mal, ungefähr so sah das vorher aus, ungefähr so sah das
vorher aus, und weiter ist das jetzt so viel schlechter lesbar, außer dass man seinen
kompletten Monitor verwendet, und mal ganz davon abgesehen, man könnte ja durchaus
irgendeinen Toggle einbauen dafür, ja, das ist ja für Hacker-Mans, für Casual-User ist
das ja nicht gemacht hier, also da kann mir jetzt keiner erzählen, dass das hier superschwer
zu lesen wär.
Ungefähr so sah das ja früher aus, und wo, wo, wo gibt es da jetzt den Arch-Wiki,
und wo gab es dann den Shitstorm dazu, Arch-Wiki-Shit-Shitstorm, das findet man nichts dazu, wahrscheinlich
auf Reddit, oder, wahrscheinlich auf Reddit, so, guck mal mal weiter, Budget-Storage-Server.
Gen-Bro, die China-Chinesen-Pros, was ist drinne, Säck, Säck, Säck, Säck, Säck,
Säck, Säck, DDR3 ist schon eine ganze Ecke älter, die Kiste also, Xeon Quad Core sagt
ja mal gar nichts aus, kann ja alles sein, maximal 8G, also ist auf jeden Fall, ist auf
jeden Fall, oder E3, okay, das ist in die Desktop Xeons gewesen, das ist 6-7 Jahre
alte Hardware, die verbrauchen auch ein bisschen mehr Strom noch, wir brauchen einen China-Keks,
das stimmt, wir brauchen einen China-Keks, ein China-Chinesen-Keks, ja, das brauchen wir
wirklich.
Ja, das ist von 2000, 2014, oder so, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ja, natürlich sind die Dinger schwer, das ist halt auch ein Kupferblock, aber, das ist
normal ins surfer hardware die kriegen ja auch die luft so durchgezogen oder ich weiß jetzt nicht
wo vorne und wo hinten ist wahrscheinlich ist wahrscheinlich ist das hier das hier vorne und
das hier hinten wird so durchgezogen quasi ist ja immer so all of its airflow from the 40 millimeter
fans place towards the middle of the case also der threat wenn ich wenn ich schon die den titel
lese das sind wieder ultra viele geträgerte linux fanboys dabei sehe ich jetzt schon in plastic
shroud that ensures three of the fans blow directly onto the heat sink and ram the motherboard the
system uses is on the lga 1155 platt der gute alte vga port der darf bei server natürlich nicht
fehlen und ihr werdet lachen so gut wie jeder server der im rechenzentrum steht heutzutage
hat immer noch einen vga port wobei wobei ich sagen muss so ganz stimmt es nicht ich war mit
phoenix vor noch nicht allzu langer zeit im rz unsere neuen dellkisten haben glaube ich neben
vga auch display port aber vga geht halt einfach company called tyan it is for ram slots a bunch
of pcie slots which aren't that important because of the systems when you form factor but would be
good in a more standard thickness case the io on this board is for usb2 ports dual gigabit ethernet
management an ipmi port vga serial and a uid led button this isn't great for a normal system but
for a server this selection of ports is fine the real feature of this board that makes it perfect
for this use case is the 14 yes 14 built-in sata ports this allows all 12 of the main drives to
play directly into the list ja wisst ihr was ich daran doof finde es ist kein hot swap das heißt du
musst auf jeden fall selbst tracken wo was angeschlossen ist das heißt du musst dir die
seriennummern sollten notieren wo was angeschlossen ist also welche platte welcher seriennummer
entspricht musst du eh machen und du musst es halt aufmachen und und also wenn du da jetzt
kein rack hast mit schienen wo du easy rausziehen kannst vom platz her aufklappen kannst und die
einzelne platte raus machen ist das dann auch nicht so schön dann lieber ganz ehrlich dann
lieber eine 2he kiste wo du die nämlich hochkant reinstecken kannst die platten und dann kannst du
die platten hochkant reinstecken und bekommst es auch in ein gehäuse und kannst hot swapen
das bringt überhaupt nichts weil das was da dran steht heißt ja noch lange nicht dass das im
system auch sda 1 wird oder sowas das ist das einzige was du machen kannst ist du musst
dir einmalig aufschreiben also wenn du kein kein gehäuse hast was das unterstützt mit
management kabel und led anzeige welche festplatte das ist das einzige was du machen kannst ist
ausgabe unter linux machen die weiß zu ordnung zu seriennummern jetzt also port zu seriennummer und
dann am besten noch ein aufkleber drauf machen was was ist dass du es wie dass du es findest
linux sagt ja nicht linux sagt ja nicht hier die dritte platte von vorne ist ausgefallen oder so da
sagt ihr entweder sd sdb oder stc oder was auch immer ist ausgefallen oder halt im zweifelsfall
def bei serial bla bla bla ist ausgefallen schön und gut aber dann musst du es halt immer noch
suchen welche welche das ist und ich glaube da hat keiner bock dann mit der lupe und der lampe
hinzugehen und drauf zu leuchten was hat es denn jetzt für eine seriennummer gehabt also sortierung
im gehäuse spiegelt sich nicht zwangsläufig wieder in sortierung in intern wie linux die
platten erkennt und das ding würde gar nicht in meinen rack reinpassen weil es
glaubt wahrscheinlich 80 zentimeter oder so ist oder das dürfte fast schon ein meter sein also
aber 80 zentimeter so eine komplette bautiefe die passt immer mini rack gar nicht rein mein
rack ist ja bloß glaubt 40 zentimeter tief pack considering how much hardware can fit in it
with the server picked out and received i could start figuring out and ordering other parts for a
system like this you ideally want ecc memory but unfortunately this doesn't really memory
because of this i hopped onto ebay looking for a ram kit that would fit my needs and budget what i
ended up getting was four four gigabytes sticks of crucial unbuffered ddr3 ram running at 1066
megahertz these four sticks cost a total of around 43 dollars which is an okay deal for unbuffered
ecc ram 16 gigabytes is an adequate amount especially for the configuration i ended up
with and luckily they installed and worked flawlessly in this system with ram picked out all that was
left to do was purchase drives i did a bunch of thinking and planning to get drives and was
waiting for good deals on higher capacity it's jetzt werden wieder die extern platten ge wie
heißt das geschackt wie lade sich das wenn man das wenn man das wenn man das raus rippt
aus so ein extern geschackt ist das glaube ich wenn die hdd ist geschackt
also es war mal eine zeit lang so dass die festplatten in solchen externen
gehäusen wenn du die ausgebaut hast die platten die drinne waren dass es billiger war sich so ein
externes gehäuse zu kaufen als die platte selbst die drives but with the looming possibility of a
drive shortage due to chia mining i eventually decide to pull the trigger on 10 8 terabyte
extern seagate drives see normally you would buy stand-alone drives but believe it or not it's
cheaper to buy the external version ja sagte ja ist immer noch so wobei ich jetzt gelesen habe
dass viele hersteller da gar nicht mehr normale sata platten drinne haben
und take the drives out of them this practice is known as shocking ja sag ich doch wenn geschackt
werden sie within the data hoarding community again i originally wanted to get something like 12 or 14
terabyte drives but i couldn't find a good enough deal so again purchase 10 8 terabyte drives an
average of a hundred twenty five dollars each this totals to twelve hundred fifty dollars spent on
mechanical drives for the array i also purchased a 500 gigabyte sata ssd to be used as a cash drive
this is the mx 500 which is a good quality sata drive and i'll be explaining more details about
using it as a cash drive later in the video with all the drives in hand i could begin shocking opening
up the packaging on one of these drives i found that was heißt das eigentlich direkt übersetzt
schack ging deutsch entleeren ah also quasi ok verstehe
i've itself some paperwork a usb cable and a power cable i start by taking the drives out of their
packaging and plugging them in to ensure they powered on and reported normal functionality once
this was done i could begin opening them up one thing to note is that taking the drives out of
the casings does void the warranty but these drives are much cheaper than their standalone
counterparts so you have to decide for yourself if the cost saving is worth it or not to get into
these enclosures you need to start by wedging something super thin which is not the stuff
in dem fall tatsächlich auch mal nicht außer acht lassen die chancen bei wie viel hat er jetzt zehn
zehn platten dass das ist aber so in den ersten eins zwei jahren mal eine kaputt geht ist nicht
so unrealistisch und umso mehr platten man hat umso sinniger finde ich sich dass tatsächlich
das normale ding vom hersteller zu kaufen weil die tauschen das ja bis zu fünf jahren oder bis
zu zehn jahre teilweise noch um die gefährlich aus mit dem cutter wir wissen aber schon dass
er sich nicht schneidet weil sonst könnte youtube das video nicht sonst könnte das video nicht
hochladen weil selbst verletzten ist ja nicht erlaubt auf youtube dann bleibt die garantie
erhalten dass es gut gut zu wissen guck mal da hat der gleichen fehler gemacht wie ich der hat
sein i fix it spachtel schon zu oft in ritzen geschoben die nicht richtig aufzumachen ging
und hat verbogen erinnert sich noch einer wo ich den wo ich wo ich den spachtel an der steckdose
komplett verbogen habe musstest du mal eine platte umtauschen ja schon mehrfach
von teuren sachen die rechnung ich muss dir ehrlich sagen ich glaube mich hat noch nicht
ein festplatten hersteller wirklich nach der rechnung gefragt dann musst du seriennummer
eingeben und auf geht's ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher aber nachdem ich fast nur wd und sie
geld habe wird es wahrscheinlich auch ich glaube wd wd wd cream musste ich ein paar umtauschen
wd cream waren das 2 terabyte wd cream musste ich einige mal umtauschen da habe ich bestimmt
45 umgetauscht über ein paar jahre also behältst du auch den teuren sachen die rechnung nö weil
ich bestell die sachen online zweifel zwei kann ich bei amazon die rechnung einfach ausdrucken
ich bestell fast nur noch online also
ich glaube ich habe letzten jahre über nichts offline gekauft wo ich eine rechnung hätte aufheben
müssen also ich vermute mal nicht dass sie das prüfen ich bin mir nicht mal so ganz sicher also
ich glaube das war folgendermaßen du gehst bei wd komando wd return hard drive guck mal probier
es doch mal aus return policy wd check drive failure product also immer
ich bin unfähig das zu finden jetzt
ich bin immer noch nicht mal sicher ob ich die überhaupt zurück schicken musste die
ein doch die muss ich zurück schicken ich glaube nicht dass die wirklich prüfen ob
das kaputt ist vielleicht wenn du jetzt so notorischer zurückschicker bist
ich habe mal eine frage du hast ja ein bisschen mehr mit den lux zu tun ich habe für ein
abschlussprojekt bei der ihk ein nassserver mit 32 gigabyte ram nun ist meine frage ist es richtig
wenn man ab 16 g nur noch 8 g swap hat also bei 32 g nur 16 g als swap oder ist das wie alle sagen
das doppelte das grundsystem mit dem das musst du dir überlegen ich habe mittlerweile gar kein
swap mehr also ich habe bei meinen linux kisten die haben 16 gigabyte ram ich habe gar kein swap mehr
ob man das ob man das machen sollte keine ahnung aber es funktioniert auf jeden fall aber
letztendlich kommt ja drauf an wartet mal letztendlich kommt ja darauf an was du erwartest
was du mit dem system machst ich glaube so eine so eine pauschale regel mit doppeltem ram ist
bei einer großen ram anzahl irgendwie unsinnig ich meine du bräuchte es ja dann quasi stelle
mal vor du hast 128 g ram dann bräuchte es ja eine extra ssd für swap ja und wenn du
und wenn du 16 g ram hast ist die frage ob ich 8 g swap noch retten also was was also wenn man
auf nummer sicher gehen will würde ich wahrscheinlich bei 16 g ram noch mal 16 g swap machen und bei 32
32 g würde ich wahrscheinlich auch noch mal irgendwie 16 g ja finde ich finde ich finde ich
sinnig ganz ehrlich aber ich würde es wahrscheinlich komplett ohne swap betreiben ab 16 g ram
wenn es ein ssd ist hast du mehr wo du speichern kannst drauf und 16 g ram musst du ja auch
erstmal voll kriegen das ist gar nicht mal so einfach außer mit fünf elektronen anwendung
und ein paar chrome tabs was ist swap das ist quasi auslagerungsdatei unter windows
braucht man eine swap datei für hibernate ich dachte das kann der anderweitige speichern
ne oder ach keine ahnung ich habe schon so lange keine liegungskiste mal hibernate iphone
habe ich auch online gekauft
bei den server würde ich nicht hibernate deswegen sage ich ja ich habe schon ewig keine liegungskiste
mal hibernate ok weil meine vms hibernate ich nicht da nehme ich die vmw Geschichte zum zum post
champen und server werden nicht hibernate
das board das little board ist just a saturday usb adapter and i may save these to use in the
future with one drive done i then had to repeat the process nine more times and here's a little
timelapse of me doing it wird geschockt geschackt wird der master schacker schacking intensifies
so with all the drives out i was ready to mount them now when shucking external drives you never
really know what you're gonna get most of the why benutzt du ein iphone und x android mäßiges ok
da kann ich jetzt wieder die aus dem weg geringverdienerkarte ziehen ich habe
mittlerweile 13 geräte bei mir daheim und ungefähr die hälfte davon ist android
the seagate external drives use iron wolf nas or even exos drives which are super high quality
and one of the reasons i originally wanted to go for the larger capacity ones inside of these
eight terabyte external drives were 10 seagate barracuda compute ones these are model number
st8000 dm 004 and i got these for about thirty dollars less per drive compared to buying these
stand alone that's what i saved around three and get geschockt schocken schocken lohnt sich
dollars buying as external ones this is when i came to a very important realization these are
actually smr drives smr or shingle magnetic recording is an inferior and outdated design
which is very unideal for certain use cases but with them all shocked i had to proceed with
the shagged and in the end it worked out fine for my use case which i'll explain in a minute to
mount these i needed a few things that didn't come with the case i needed these little rubber
gaskets that i got off of amazon and some 630 second bolts that i got from my local hardware
store the gasket slips over the bolt that one is secured into each of the four bottom mounting
holes on the drive i installed four into each meaning 40 once again with anti-vibrations nipple
40 gaskets the first one was brought to mount number one the sata data and power was plugged in
it was lowered down and then slid back to secure all four gaskets into place with the first one
done all i had to do was install the other nine drives one at a time into mounts two through ten
with that completed the last component i had to install was the cash drive which is in mount
11 and currently not secured but i will probably mount it with some double-sided tape in the
future with that done i needed to decide what kind of os and file system i'd be using with this i
originally debated between true nascore with a zfs raid z2 file system but because of the way
zfs stripes data across the array shows that smr drives would not be good to use in that kind of
ja kann ich mir vorstellen dass das warum will er denn zfs machen wenn er kein kein rate gedöns macht
weil es hat durchaus auch so vorteil aber ich glaube nicht dass er die braucht ja ich glaube
der will keine snapshots machen und keine off-site zfs backups und und sonstige dinger
mal gucken was er einstellt schauen wir mal
er will ja kein rate machen glaube ich zumindest deswegen verstehe ich noch
weniger was er mit mit zfs hat
set up this made the choice to use unrate much easier now unrate is paid software but it's
unrate warum stehen die alle so auf unrate ich verstehe es nicht
alternative to raid or zfs ich muss mit leute wir gucken uns das wir gucken uns das mal an
streben ideen unrate wir gucken uns das mal in einem stream an was was haben die alle nur mit
unrate das was ich bisher davon gesehen habe hat mich so null überzeugt moment die geek freaks das
ist doch der das ist doch das ist doch dieser channel auf youtube mit dem wir optimieren
windows auf 15 mb runter und sowas ach nee das ist hier hochgeladen download
kann man das wenigstens ausprobieren ohne lizenz
basic
ich es hat mich bisher überhaupt nicht geschockt aber ich würde es für den stream mal ausprobieren
ja 90 tage ok machen wir
ja aber aber du kriegst auch keine performance boost genau aber
der heim erinnert noch und
zu dem Erreifungsgerät. Für mich ist das toll, weil es eine Menge archivales Stauern bedeutet,
das reliable und mit einer hohen Anwendung sein sollte, aber der langsame Geschwindigkeit bedeutet,
dass das Editing direkt vom Erreifungsgerät nicht möglich ist, was wiederum gut für mich ist.
Setzten Unrate ist sehr einfach und ich habe einen Guide von Juan M. Tech verfolgt,
der eine tolle Arbeit auf Erklärung der Basis des Setzes gemacht hat.
Ich habe gar kein ZFS mehr am Start, ich hatte ja die, kennt ihr ja, habe ich euch ja letztens
im Video gesehen hier, Server Raum, Server Raum, da liegt er, da liegt die alte 4 HE-Kiste.
Mit, das hatte ZFS-Rate drauf, das war eine richtig fette Kiste für damals 8 Kerne Xeon,
ich glaube 48G RAM und sonst was, das war ein richtig fettes Ding, sogar mit Lüfter-Mod hier.
Und das habe ich mittlerweile alles rausgeschmissen zugunsten einer Low-Power-Intel-Kiste.
Hastest du schon mal einen Stream über Ansible gemacht?
Ja, wir verwenden Ansible öfters hier im Stream und wir haben auch mal zusammen komplett
gelernt und Files from scratch erstellt.
Wie funktioniert das? Wie funktioniert das bei Android und USB? Startet das immer von
USB und schreibt das restliche Betriebssystem in RAM oder wie ist das? Sodass es weiterläuft,
wenn ein USB abkackt. Ja, ja das ist sinnvoll. Ja, ich habe nicht zugehört. Und wenn man
Settings speichern will, muss man wahrscheinlich explizit sagen, ja ich will jetzt USB schreiben,
wahrscheinlich. Die Streams gibt es archiviert, ja. Die Streams gibt es übrigens archiviert auch,
mach mal Ausrufezeichen Archiv, ich weiß nicht, ob das schon geupdatet wurde. Oder was? Archiv?
Ach so Archiv. Ja, also es ist noch nicht alles hochgeladen. Es gibt jetzt einen VOD-Channel,
wo findige Mods die ganzen alten VODs hochladen von mir. Aktuell gibt es noch einen Google Drive.
Ach guck mal, es gibt schon, alter, guck mal die Mods sind mal richtig, richtig advanced,
guckt euch das mal an. Kürzliches Streams. Gibt sogar, gibt sogar hier Übersicht, Jahresansicht,
kürzlich Stats, richtig advanceder Shit, den wir hier langsam haben. Also auf den YouTube-Channel
kommen alle VODs, den betreibe nicht ich und ist auch nicht verlinkt mit meinem YouTube-Account,
weil falls Strike wegen Musik im Hintergrund oder so. Und aktuell gibt es, die TXT-Suche geht noch,
gibt es einen Google Drive, wo man gucken kann.
Hat jemand schon mal versucht, ob man das mit Ubuntu auch gut hinbekommt? Ubuntu booten von USB
und quasi dann RAM, komplett im RAM laufen lassen, read only. Da muss man bestimmt ein bisschen
selbst von Hand wurschteln, bis das funktioniert. Ja, das probieren wir demnächst auch mal aus.
Wie gesagt, mich hat das bisher nicht überzeugt, aber wir probieren das mal für den Stream aus,
mal wirklich komplett live, mal ausprobieren. Vielleicht machen wir es sogar auf einer echten
Hardware-Kiste, weil ich habe ja meine 4HE-Kiste hier noch rumstehen.
Okay, sind 60 TI am Ende noch übrig. Leute, sind es jetzt TBbyte oder TBbyte oder Terabyte oder
oder was ist das jetzt? Also das sind auf jeden Fall in bytes. So, aber ich kann es mir einfach
nicht merken. Also TBbytes sind 1024 oder wie ist das?
Okay, wie sieht es mit Stromverbrauch aus? Das ist das, was mich eigentlich interessieren würde.
Hat er irgendwas zum Thema Stromverbrauch gesagt? Das zieht schon ein bisschen was. Also ich denke,
das könnte durchaus 200 Watt Eidl ziehen. Auf was würdet ihr so tippen? 200 Watt Eidl?
Ich denke, es kommt wahrscheinlich ganz gut hin. Hast du einen Pop-Schutz auf deinem Mikrofon?
Ja, auf dem normalen schon, auf dem Headset nicht. Auf dem Headset ist halt das ganz normale Teil
drauf. Ja, ja klar ist bei ihm der Strom billiger. Das ist ja das Ding. Bei uns in Deutschland ist
Strom allübelst teuer. Und ich muss aufs Klo. 50 Watt Eidl. Nee, das braucht auf jeden Fall mehr
als 50 Watt Eidl. Okay, wenn alle Festplatten im Sleep sind vielleicht, wenn alle Festplatten im Sleep
sind, der Rest gar nichts macht vielleicht. Leute, ich muss aufs Klo. Ich gehe jetzt off.
Vielleicht mache ich nachher nochmal streamen. Vielleicht mache ich nachher nochmal streamen
und wir basteln ein bisschen, muss ich mal gucken. Schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid.
Heute ein bisschen kürzerer Aufwachstream, weil wir jetzt drei Tage in Folge gestreamt.
Gestern insgesamt über sechs Stunden. Reicht. Bis denn. Macht's gut. Wir sehen uns Leute. See you.